TIMOTHY: Let's now take a
quick look at Google Cloud.
There are two things
that I want to check out,
and Jen is here to
tell us all about them.
Hi, Jen.
JEN: Hi, Timothy.
TIMOTHY: So what's this?
Because I really
want to play with it.
JEN: So this is
Kubernetes Whack-a-Pod,
and it is a demo in which
you battle Kubernetes,
where you are trying to
take down a service by being
the cast monkey.
While you're doing
that, Kubernetes,
which is a container
orchestration
framework and
open-source project,
will try and keep
your web service up.
TIMOTHY: That sounds like fun.
I'm going to totally
try and take it down.
JEN: Yeah.
Give it a spin.
You're gonna hit the
button, and you're
going to battle for 30 seconds.
Ready?
Here you go.
So you're doing great.
Kubernetes is bringing those
containers right back up.
The yellow mole is special.
It will take out the
entire web app in one go.
Oh!
And it's down.
But Kubernetes is already
bringing those containers
right back up.
You're doing great.
Four, three, two,
one, and you are done.
So during your 30-second
battle, you took out 58 pods
and caused nine
seconds of downtime.
But it seems Kubernetes is
victorious in getting about 70%
up-time.
But that's still a
very good attempt.
TIMOTHY: Awesome.
That was a lot of fun.
JEN: Yeah.
I love that demo.
TIMOTHY: All right.
So I'd also like to
check out Spanner,
because I think Spanner's, like,
one of the coolest things ever
created.
JEN: Spanner is pretty amazing.
TIMOTHY: So I want to check
out what this visualization is.
Maybe you can give
us a quick rundown
of what Spanner is, and then
tell us what's happening here.
JEN: Sure.
So Spanner is a
managed SQL database.
What makes it special is, it
is massively, horizontally
scalable, and can handle
huge amounts of traffic.
And you still have
the wonderful features
you would expect
from a SQL database
like queries, transactions,
and other neat, shiny things
like live migrations.
Yeah, and it's fully managed,
which is pretty cool.
Because who likes managing
your own database?
This is a view of
the schema that
is an example schema
on Spanner, which
is the same thing being used
to power the demo on the screen
next to us.
TIMOTHY: If I can, I think one
of the things that I've always
really liked about
Spanner is the fact
that it stays in sync, even
though things are happening
in different data centers.
Can you tell me a
little more about that?
JEN: Yeah.
That's a great point.
That's one of the special
features of Spanner.
In this particular
demo, we have Spanner
running on three
different data centers,
on three different continents,
all over the world.
And yet, due to some magic
involving atomic clocks
and very precise
time keeping, we
can still serialize
all those transactions
and maintain that consistency.
TIMOTHY: That's cool.
So what is actually
happening on the screen here?
JEN: So on this
screen right here,
we are simulating a pretty
amazing ticket sales
event, where apparently,
whatever this ticket sales
event is, we are selling
137,000 tickets every minute.
And so far, this
demo, which I believe
we started this morning,
has sold 238 million tickets
during its run-through.
You can see they're
distributed across the world,
and even despite all that
really high throughput,
we're still maintaining
about a second of latency
on those transactions.
TIMOTHY: That's amazing.
OK.
Is there anything else you
want to tell us about what's
happening here at I/O?
JEN: It's a great show.
But other than that, I think
you found the fun spots.
TIMOTHY: (LAUGHING)
All right, thanks, Jen.
JEN: Thanks so much, Timothy.
See you later.
TIMOTHY: OK, see ya.
I'll be honest.
It's not a party if
there's not a photobooth.
So I found the
photobooth, and the guy
who built the
photobooth, Alex, who's
going to tell us all about it.
ALEX: Hey, guys.
So this is a talking photobooth.
For an operating system,
it uses Android Things.
And you talk to it using
the Google Assistant,
and it uploads photos to
the Cloud using Firebase.
TIMOTHY: Awesome.
Should we try it out?
ALEX: Yeah, let's do this.
TIMOTHY: Where does
it talk out of?
There?
ALEX: [INAUDIBLE]
TIMOTHY: What about the speaker?
ALEX: Right here.
TIMOTHY: OK.
OK, Google.
Let me talk to the
I/O Photobooth.
WOMAN'S VOICE (ON
PHOTOBOOTH): Sure.
Here's I/O Photobooth.
Booth.
MAN'S VOICE (ON PHOTOBOOTH): Hi.
I'm the I/O Photobooth.
OK.
Taking a picture.
Three, two-- don't
look so serious.
You're in a talking photobooth--
one.
[SHUTTER SOUND]
Do you like it?
TIMOTHY: Yes.
MAN'S VOICE (ON
PHOTOBOOTH): Do you
want to add some
style to your photo?
TIMOTHY: Yes.
MAN'S VOICE (ON
PHOTOBOOTH): Just a minute.
Downloading styles.
[DIAL-UP SOUND]
[LAUGHTER]
TIMOTHY: That's 56K.
I can tell.
MAN'S VOICE (ON
PHOTOBOOTH): Here you go.
I'm uploading your photo now.
Can I show this on
my Twitter, too?
TIMOTHY: Yeah.
ALEX: Yeah, yeah.
MAN'S VOICE (ON
PHOTOBOOTH): Got it.
Uploading your photo.
Printing a link
in the photo now.
Don't forget to share
your photo with #io17,
and have a great time at I/O.
TIMOTHY: That was awesome.
ALEX: Thanks.
It was a lot of fun.
TIMOTHY: All right.
Thanks, Alex.
So I'm here with
Doug from Firebase,
and there's a lot going
on in the Firebase area.
A lot that developers
have already
been able to play with
and know pretty well,
but there's also some
new stuff, and I've
asked Doug to show us
some of that new stuff.
DOUG: Yeah.
So announced today-- actually
yesterday at the keynote,
we found out that Firebase
now has Firebase performance
monitoring, which
is a set of tools
you can use to
measure and monitor
the performance of your app.
So let's take a look at that.
So this is the dashboard.
What we have here is an
overview of the performance
of your apps, so we have
traces by frequency.
You could think of a trace
like a window of time
that's of interest in your app.
Also, we can look at the latency
of your network connections
all over the world.
You can also see the success
rate of your app over time,
so it looks like things are
getting a little bit worse
for this app as time goes on.
So that may be something
to pay attention to.
Now, if we drill into
traces a little bit,
we can see that there are a
collection of automatic traces.
So we capture these for
free, automatically,
and here are some
custom traces that
have been defined by the app.
So you have the
flexibility to write code
to get some performance,
or you can just
let it do things automatically.
Now, if we get a
network request,
we can get a breakdown of all
the HTTP transactions that
are going in here.
And you'll notice that
there are some wild cards,
so we're actually bundling up
different kinds of requests
that look the same but actually
have different parameters.
And you can see, for
this set of APIs,
what's the average response
time, what's the success rate,
and the number of requests
that have gone to the system.
You can click through this
and see how it's going.
So you know, you're probably
using a lot of different SDKs,
you'd probably want to
know how they perform,
you'd probably want to know
how the app is performing
from your user's point of
view, and this is a great tool
to get that done.
TIMOTHY: Awesome, Doug.
That's really cool,
and it's really neat
to see all the data in this way.
DOUG: Yeah.
It's definitely very helpful.
It's definitely also
very interactive.
It's not just a dashboard
that you look at.
It's a dashboard that
you interact with.
TIMOTHY: That's actually
one of the really cool parts
about being at I/O--
that if I were to just set
this up on my app right away,
I might not have all
this data right away,
but we're showing
a demo here where
we've collected a
bunch of that data
so you can see what
it's like once you've
invested for a while.
DOUG: Yeah, definitely.
There's nothing worse than
opening up the dashboard
and having nothing
staring you in the face.
Right?
It's nice to be able to see what
you're getting into before you
actually get into it.
TIMOTHY: Absolutely.